how much time today in 2018 do you
dedicate to writing I write I don't
write in a disciplined way in that and
like a timing thing like oh you know a
certain hours of the day every single
day Monday through Friday or anything I
thought I'm one of those guys that sort
of writes in bunches and writes certain
times or there's certain days that I
don't write I wrote five pages this
morning it wasn't I did not do that for
the benefit of the film courage
interview I just I just was like
yesterday I was like I need to like I
really want and I I'm on rewriting this
thing and I've been going around and
around with it and I started really a
paid like a different totally different
approach on this script and so I was
like I need to start really che I have
two projects that I'm working on right
now both of them too direct
and both of them have gone through a lot
of different development and they're
both there's people involved and already
producers and stuff so and I want to
make one of them next year so I'm just
like I really need to like you know and
I found myself bored getting really
frustrated with this one thing and
realizing it's like I'm at that point
where I was like I'm really just I don't
know if I can figure this out and I was
like you got to hang in there and I did
and then I came up with a way in to the
to open it again and so I wrote like a
page on Friday because I was so I had
this idea for the opening so I wrote the
page and then today I were like four
more pages so I'm like they were on page
five then I sent it over to my staff I
send my pages in and they kind of take a
look at them and give me like quick
feedback on like if I'm going the right
direction or something like that and
then this afternoon I'm gonna go to the
other project where I'm really outlining
it because it's a heist and so I it's
like I've got to do a lot of
architecture stuff with it you know it's
like whereas this other thing is it very
much like a feel like a love wise a type
of movie
where there's a protagonist and they're
on a mission kind of thing and it's that
kind of a piece so it's very much an
extension of like love Liza but in that
structurally a character or kind of
thing but I'm gonna be directing it so
you said about getting bored and so when
you get that signal that other than just
nothing's happening what's your process
do you come you cannot abandon it every
every script you know you get bored with
something that means you're actually
getting somewhere with the movie people
are amateurs primarily because they
can't get through the professional
period of hating what they're writing
bored frustrated looking at every page
going to hate all these scenes I'm like
I'm like little if there's no magic here
I don't like I do not enjoy myself it's
not gratifying so you have to suck it up
and get through that period you can't
you know I'm bored
you're just gonna go right back to where
that point is again so I everything I've
ever I mean this is a FEMA there's a
famous quote from Kurosawa about this
that I look at almost every single day
the quote and it's but you know it's you
just put it up on your little thing with
this video maybe because people probably
ask about what it is but it's basically
he talks about every script falling into
despair and he uses the word despair you
know and despair is a strong word but
that's exactly what that is it's like
it's like I can't figure this out I
don't know how to figure this out and I
just want to I really want to start with
this because this other thing I know
what to do with it I'm gonna start it
and it's gonna be okay
not knowing that or not remembering that
everything you write you come to that
place of despair and the art the artists
the the writer the director the actor
whatever has to walk through that period
of like that sort of desert period of
the creative process or they're not
going to you know because then something
will click and that's what happened is I
hung in there with this one thing where
I was recently gone
and then I came up with an image and I
had some input from somebody like just
life experience and I had such an
incident I sort of was like what if I
move it and I started over there and I
do that now sudden I had a I had an idea
and then I was done I was like okay this
is how it is and I had oh I cracked my
problem and suddenly I was like okay I'm
back in the saddle I got this thing
going now I can incorporate the other
things I've been working on that I still
like but I got through that period of
like of just discouragement so is that
something that when you know your quote
in boredom that that you have a ritual
for because I'm sure it's not a ritual
it's just the ritual is staying patient
you know people don't have any patience
you know and they don't have you know
corporate structures I think don't allow
for patients when they're making studio
pictures and stuff it doesn't you know
it's like when they announce a release
date and the scripts not done well
that's counterintuitive actually you
know because you're not that's like okay
I'm gonna show you this but I haven't
written it yet
that creates dysfunction and so that's
why I think a lot of bets are off and
that's why you have projects not really
work out you go to a movie going to the
theater and you're like what just happen
there and it's very difficult so because
it really eliminates the principle of
patience because you're not gonna be
like well let's pump the brakes III
really this thing needs about six more
months I got to figure this out can we
move this release date back for a year
and a half you know and tell the Disney
stockholders that you know the Star Wars
movies not gonna come out for four years
because we want to make sure that the
script is good you know and that's not
gonna that's not gonna work so and
that's okay and it doesn't mean that you
can I mean the guys are Oh Casablanca I
mean you know you can write under duress
and and and it can be successful having
deadlines in structure is fine I mean
it's like but overall when you are stuck
having patience and being like do not
give up do not
hang in there and don't like change
gears just hang in there and I did I
didn't a couple weeks it was maybe a
little bit of time but I was kind of
going and then all of a sudden but I but
I kept telling myself no no no just keep
hanging in there and like what can you
do here you're not gonna move off this
is you have to finish
there's nothing palatable about working
on this script at all it's just there's
nothing there you want to start working
on something else you have a number of
ideas they you're so much sexier
attractive you want to jump into but
it's like you can't let go of this you
have to stay hang in there
so I always just so whatever the process
is doesn't matter it's just exhibiting
patience and realizing it's like if you
hang in there the path is gonna open up
according to Kurosawa the path will open
up and then you'll and then you'll be
like oh and then the light bulb will go
off in it and that's what's happened
with everything really Apocalypse Now
you don't want it to become your what is
it heart of darkness or did you see the
documentary yeah yeah you know it's
really good but that's also pardon but I
think that I mean absolutely I think I
mean if anything you know what Coppola
was doing with Apocalypse Now is having
patience and hanging in there because it
would have there were a lot of places
you want to give up but he you have to
fight you know you have to fight through
knowing and also maintaining like no I
have to tell the truth I want to be
original I want to be compelling I want
to make a message of choices I'm not
gonna like cuz you know to get through
the darkness you you're bored or you're
stuck because you're not giving up and
you're not like compromising you know
you're not saying well no let's just
shoot it anyways it's good enough it's
already done who cares if you haven't
figured out the third act let's just do
it it's it's good enough it doesn't have
to be perfect you know I had a filmmaker
say to me wants Gordy it doesn't have to
be perfect and it's like you're right
it's never going to be perfect but you
will but what it's implying it's like a
little bit of like disregard of like who
can
errors if you know something is Korra's
kind of crap or it does not believable
it's not logical you know or it's not
vulnerable or doesn't it's not clear or
whatever all the problems if you're
aware of problems but you're like well
who cares you know then you're not going
to make somebody's favorite movie that
way right so
you